what's the deal with airplane peanuts
peanuts it's official Brian Callan and
Brendan Schaub will both be attending
skank Fest 2023 this year in Las Vegas
Nevada and the internet could not be
happier skank Fest is by far the premier
Comedy Festival in the country every
year with hundreds of the most talented
comedians on Earth stacking every single
show but the fire and the kid crew may
be there for different reasons to fully
understand why Brendan Shaw attending
skank Fest is such a big deal it's
important we look at his history with
the members of the Legion of skank's
crew a lot of comedians have made jokes
about Brendan Schaub related to Gringo
Poppy the Bobby Lee incident or the
Annie Letterman drama but nobody in
comedy has taken more public shots at
Brendan's shop than the Legion of skanks
I'm sitting here writing down my jokes
oh you guys happen to catch me right now
thank you he's practicing writing his
own name
all right so uh all this tragic stuff
happens and then the most tragic thing
that happened in April was Brandon Trump
releases Gringo Poppy
this is one of the things people
appreciate most about the Legion of
skanks they don't pull any punches or
tiptoe around any subjects you can
always count on these guys to say
exactly what everyone else is secretly
thinking but doesn't want to say out
loud without being scared of any
backlash and they've done this many
times in regards to Brendan Schaub they
also make it clear every single time
these comments are intended to be funny
and that they don't actually hate
Brendan or even know him that well to
begin with can I tell you why I've taken
shots and I've made jokes is because
it's like it's like the button you're
not supposed to push for some reason I
don't know why for some reason it's like
a thing you're not supposed to say so it
makes me want to say it more it's a
comic I don't know that's always been
what it is whatever I don't actually
have any ill will toward the guy I've
literally met him one time he seems like
he's a lot of mutual friends Brendan's
shop is like the Michael Jordan of
receiving hate online and honestly it's
so no signs of slowing down over the
past few years but for a long time
people have been saying the best move
Brendan could ever make would be to play
into all the jokes about him on Reddit
and show some self-deprecation for once
which is something he's yet to try thus
far oh my goodness you got a camera oh
wow do you remember that no I don't
that's it you have a what do you call
that a moose a moose knuckle knuckle
denim vagina no those are some big nuts
those aren't big nuts that's a denim
vagina no that's my nut split like that
you know you know what the problem is
the Gene's too tight no that's not the
problem no I know where you're going
with this Howie my nuts are too big
that's not what you're going what size
shoes do you wear 13. well you know what
that means I mean you have a giant
vagina this is exactly why it's going to
be so interesting to see what happens
this year at skank Fest if Brendan is
willing to play into jokes made at his
expense the fighter and kids appearance
has potential to be the best show of the
entire Festival but if he's not willing
to be the butt of some jokes I'm
honestly not sure what's gonna happen my
guess is it'll turn into an awkward slow
bomb of a show rather than some angry
mob of audience members yelling at
Brendan's job I honestly think people
don't really hate him as much as they
like to make it seem sometimes or at
least they don't want him to actually
stop creating new content because then
they'd have nothing to react to skank
Fester they uh I mean are they are the
are they a very forgiving crowd yeah
yeah fan base are so Savage they're
Savage [__] yeah but they're
his that's his no but they're also like
here's the thing here's the greatest
thing about them and the problem with it
we've made this like safe Zone own for
like just [__] go for it yeah and the
thing is 90 of them are just not funny
even if it's been like a tumultuous
thing with them it's like meeting Erica
Kane and hating Susan Lucci do you know
what I mean like it's not that thing
it's like it's like no you love Susan
Lucci because she's everyone like well
that's why we know we're all ourselves
yeah trust like in their minds like
they're so removable we're character
isn't a thing yeah you know what I mean
and so that's how and when they see the
characters whether it's someone who they
[__] on or they uh overly dude I mean
they're so excited to see all of
everyone because no one's ever like
that's why are you guys hanging out with
the guys we [__] like it's like yeah
they're our friends Lewis was like have
Brandon come on the [__] on the show
it'll be a blast yeah yeah I think they
were hoping to have you guys a skank
Fest his fans think it's lame his fans
think it's lame for us to bring him on
to our podcast unless we bring them down
to our podcast to specifically try to
fist fight him or ruin his life the
other thing that could possibly make
this show feel like a disappointment in
the eyes of Comedy fans is if the skanks
don't press Brendan shop how enough to
his face about all the drama they like
to discuss when he's not around yeah I
like I love fighter and the kid I think
it's a great show like I've got no great
ones on the podcast huh you love the
fighter and the kid well I mean I don't
like just watch it religiously no it's a
good it's I love MMA
you know I'm not even saying that that
it would happen a fighter and the kid
Legion is gang's crossover but if I if
we brought somebody shitty to him yeah
I'm not bringing anybody on the show to
be [__] unless it was like it was set up
whatever shank I would never Shanghai
somebody to be shitty I would I would if
you're gonna have some have it out with
somebody on the thing and that's kind of
like the idea but like yeah
To sideswipe I remember that was funny
like first of all I think we asked Brian
Cowen some pretty
uh he answered some pretty good
questions on that lie detector test yeah
but like again we're not going to have
him on to [__] him over it's just like
right yeah why would anybody do the show
ever yeah so yeah this is a shitty thing
to do I don't know I'm not trying to
like if we're if we're busting someone's
balls it's always with the spirit of
like this is funny we're all gonna laugh
about it it's not like we're gonna get
it it definitely makes sense what they
said about not wanting to invite someone
onto their show just to be shitty to
them and I think that's more than
understandable personally I'm not
invested enough into this Brennan shop
subculture to say this with 100
certainty but I would assume that if the
skanks bring up at least the main two or
three popular Brandon stories in a funny
way that should suffice to Their
audience as them not going soft either
way I'm planning on attending skank Fest
myself this year to see how this all
unfolds firsthand and report it back to
you guys right here on the joke World
comedy news update let me know in the
comments if you're going to be at skank
Fest in October tickets went on sale for
the first time earlier this week the
final round of this year's comedy
podcast March Madness Tournament is
underway right now over at
watchcomedy.live the tournament's been a
great success so far this year there's
over 15 000 votes last round which is
amazing to see the championship matchup
is we might be drunks taking on Chrissy
chaos just like the real college
basketball tournament this year was full
of wild exciting upsets which is a lot
more fun than just a popularity contest
if you ask me the final vote count will
be hidden to the public until the
winners announced this Thursday April
13th right here on joke World we'll be
making a video recapping the winners
from every single matchup this year and
crowning the 2023 joke World podcast
March Madness Tournament champion you're
not going to want to miss it so make
sure your post notifications are turned
on and you can go vote right now using
the link in our bio guest spots from
last week your mom's house had on Ryan
sickler two bears one cave was Burton
Tom and Bert kill Tony this week was
with Ron White Whiskey ginger head on
Big Jay oakerson big J was also on take
your shoes off Bert Kreischer was on the
Tim Dillon show he was also on stavy's
world and Shane Gillis was on Ru garbage
how often do you wash in the hair
how often do I like actually putting
shampoo yeah yeah every day and what's
kind of soap are you using
uh there's some Dove soap in there
yeah yeah man you are old school I tell
you that why yeah you should be using
something fancy something nice yeah well
Keels or something I was using hand soap
for a while
so I'm living high on the hog now dude I
didn't buy any soap and I just took it
off the sink
yeah well [__] it it works
good
[Laughter]
I think that's normal no it's not this
past weekend with Theo Von was a solo
episode The Joe Rogan Experience talked
with Ari shaffir and Big Jay oakerson as
well as Mike vacchione flagrant had on
Noel Miller Rick Glassman was on the
Honeydew Esther pavitsky was on Chrissy
chaos Greg Fitzsimmons was the guest on
the Heartland Highway Nick Kroll was on
the blocks podcast we might be drunk out
on Dustin Nickerson and Tom Collins and
Dan Soder was on you know what dude as
far as new stand-up specials are either
out right now or coming out soon Stavros
halcus has a new crowd work special
coming out on YouTube Wednesday April
12th and judging from all of savvy's
other crowd work Clips this special
should be highly entertaining what do
you do now
okay no disrespect how hard is it it's
like
whoa look at that
it's another one
who whose company is it it's an
architecture an architecture okay okay
so you fail that engineering but you got
an architecture degree or okay wow
architecture and you design pools again
that's that can't be the highest level
of architecture
in general last week was massive for new
stand-up specials we had Ryan sickler
Big Jay oakerson and Matt Rife uploading
specials onto YouTube as well as Louis
CK's latest special premiering on his
website and coming out soon John Mulaney
baby Jay will be on Netflix April 24th
and Jimmy o Yang has a new special
coming to Amazon on May 2nd one more
final piece of Comedy news that came out
of last week Bobby Lee dedicated the
latest episode of tigerbelly to publicly
addressing the numerous attempts to
cancel him on Tick Tock we posted an
entire in-depth breakdown of the
situation A few days ago so if you want
to learn more about what's going on with
Bobby be sure to check out that video
next and while you're at it hit
subscribe come on
[Music]
thank you